here's my setup is my setup and can I
just say this question is a question
it's um a make or break on the set up
which is why you might have started off
in your life okay why what I am I
getting anywhere or why does it look so
awful okay how does it come out so let's
begin slowly think through it and
there's a couple of yeah kind of weed
ways that you can have a look at this
number one simplify things for you and
number two well actually allow you to
solvent so here's a scenario a is eight
kilometers north and B is six kilometers
east oh oh ok I'm going to pause for a
second right now I have told you guys
before and I've modeled for you that
generally as I read the question I start
to put information on now I'm going to
do exactly that there's a reason why
though I have two diagrams because as it
happens in this case just doing that
flat out is actually very unhelpful and
i will show you why in a second okay so
we've got eight kilometers here and six
kilometers here okay raise your hand if
your diagram looks exactly like mine so
far yeah okay all right good yeah no
problem like I said this is the way that
I generally will approach something i'm
reading and i'm writing okay two men
start walking at the same time from a
and b respectively toward Earth and four
kilometers per hour each so at this
point
at this point here's the next piece of
information that I close beer okay this
guy is walking this way and this guy is
walking that way and they both have
these speed right so I say okay this
guy's going that way at four kilometers
per hour and this guy is also going this
way at four kilometers per hour and then
I've got all the information that the
question has given me that's it isn't
there's no other data okay then it says
find their distance apart after T hours
okay then pause and you look and you're
kind of in trouble okay because when you
have a look at this well i know i have
speeds on there i know i have race but
as i've constructed the diagram
everything on my diagram is constant do
you notice that it's like look this
distance it is six and this distance it
is eight and that's what it is there's
new variables involved okay so right
away like most people work out okay well
i want a distance between A&B so you
draw that line in there okay okay and
I'm like okay there's the distance I
want or call that thanks but at this
particular second all I know is that
this is a six eight ten triangle right
so I know they start off ten kilometers
apart but then I don't know anything
else apart from that I don't have any
tools to work out how are things
changing and the change is the key like
I need to work out after T hours not
just at a particular time okay to raise
a question more but you just go like
okay now I'm what you say can't you just
I'd like to suggest that that's actually
a huge conceptual leap so let me let me
rewind okay like I said this is kind of
a sailor way to approach things because
you're reading information you're
putting it on to your diagram okay but
as I just mentioned this is actually a
very unhelpful way to construct the
question and on how you're going to
solve it so let me begin again I've got
a and I've got being but what I'm going
to try and do is bake into this diagram
the fact
things can change okay so when we think
about this day here right I know at a
particular moment it's eight right
actually when I start right in other
words when the time is zero there's my
variable right time will progress and
these guys will move okay remember when
we started looking at the UM at the
pieces of paper and we fall of them and
so on right there's lots of different
things that are changing for example
this guy's moving this guy's moving but
one thing is changing underneath right
if you want to think about it that way
this question must have a parameter
right there must be one number that if i
change that everything else changes in
response and in this question it's time
and that's why the first part a says
find their distance apart after T hours
time is a very very common parameter
which actually mentioned to you at the
beginning we started parametrics okay so
therefore remembering that this thing is
changing and it's getting smaller at
least it's getting smaller for a while
eventually it will get bigger okay this
starts at eight it started a and it
drops right it starts at eight and it
reduces by some amount okay and the
amount increases as time increases right
well after the first hour it should be
four and then after the second hour it
should be zero and then after the third
hour it'll be negative for like I've
gone in this direction yeah and then
negative eight and so on now when you
have a look at these guys ate and then
four and zero and then there before
don't pop up above right this is a
linear function isn't it okay it also
happens to be an AP but we're trying to
think about this is in a continuous form
because I actually do have numbers all
the way between here so if I have a
straight line a linear function I start
at eight and each time I'm going down by
four so therefore that is my statement
for the distance a oh right and some
people will see that very very quickly
most of us will not and most was kind of
need to be have our handheld to be like
okay this is a
the different conception of thinking
about that distance from this this is
variable now this is a variable once you
have that established you can see it
doesn't take that much thought to our
imagination to call this 6-14 okay so
now that I have both of these distances
expressed in terms of parameter time now
i can get a B also expressed in terms of
the promo right there are all these
things changing but they all depend on
time so I'm going to put my line in
there now according to Pythagoras I
would say the square of the hypotenuse
is equal to and then I've got these guys
write the sum of the squares of the
shortage sighs okay now ordinarily
therefore i would say this actual
distance this actual distance is the
square root of all of this okay now in
fact i'm going to go ahead i'm going to
write that on because that is what the
distance is square root on but let's
just pause for a second we have two
reasons to pause at this moment the
first reason to pause it is what are we
going to do with this thing in a minute
what's what's the point yeah again what
I need to differentiate is because I
want to make that a minimum I want it to
be the smallest okay by the way I kind
of implied it before but a lot of people
read this question they're like well
isn't the smallest for marriage oh but
if you have a look at the question
there's nothing that tells you the
question that they actually stopped at
oh right so this guy's going to just
keep on going past and this guy's going
to keep on going puss and they're not
just get it in there the distance will
20 ok so number 1 i'm gonna have to
differentiate now that that looks
terrible i do you really want to do
Reggie eighth that all of that to the
power half I mean we can do it but gee
it's gonna be a mess is there another
way right sometimes there is not but I
might as well ask can I work out another
way okay did you want to Rizzoli
yeah I'm not quite there yet I'm you can
see it's partly well I need to ask the
next question in order to get to the
math okay is it okay wait yeah okay so i
can i can take these guys right
underneath here and expanding will be
helpful like it'll it'll mean I don't
have to separate terms underneath you
that will be um yeah it'll turn into
well it's just a be a quadratic of some
kind right so that's that's better that
is objectively better okay but it's
still kind of gross okay now there's a
second reason it's in the question
itself did you read the whole question
did you notice you should always when
you've got multiple parts should always
read a whole question because remember
where you're going to go will kind of
heart how you do the earlier part so you
already noticed is Part B which says
hence find when and where the men are
years to each other which means when is
this the smallest so there's there's
your match me right but then underneath
they very helpfully give you a clue they
say note to minimize the distance that's
that's the stomach you know if the
distance is equivalent to minimizing the
distance squared what's that about okay
so let's think about this right if I
gave you a table value okay and I said
okay at a certain time what's your
distance away from you know a point like
80 origin okay now suppose I have some
weird function here where according to
time progressing another one just where
i'm going to say your distance it just
fluctuates all over the place okay so
suppose the distance i don't know it
starts off it imagine if we ate and then
it goes up to 10 and then it goes down
to five and one up to six and so okay so
if you have some values right you don't
need to differentiate to work out where
the minimum is it's right there okay but
this is if you know what the values are
right over here I have things as a
function I don't actually know what the
numbers are I could work on map boy is
that a blunt tool to use on this I want
to use calculus right now I don't have
the distance in a nice form I've got the
distance in agarose for with a square
root in it okay but if i square this
time
if I have an expression for the distance
squared right can you see that finding
the minimum distance where is really the
same as finding the minimum distance let
me show you okay these are easy numbers
so the distance where we 6425 136 and 49
okay now if what I'm after is tell me
when tell me when I had the shortest
distance ok answering that question is
saying the same as telling me when the
square of the distance is also a minimum
right do you see the minimum here
corresponds to the minimum here which
will give you the same time I'm away ok
now that's a bit weird why why do the
distance squared well I hope I tried to
justify it with the first point because
I don't want to find the distance by
itself it's gross or to avoid that if I
possibly can and I can ok so what am I
going to do I have an expression for the
distance squared there it is that's the
actual thing I'm I've done ok so
therefore i'm going to differentiate
this the whole thing the square thing
with respect to time ok that's what I'm
going to do so that is my answer to part
a that's that's the distance apart after
T hours I suppose you could the
suggestion was to simplify what happens
when you expand everything under the
skybridge rumors don't want to say it a
hundred hundred minus ok
so that's the distance